[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
naturgewalten können einen traumurlaub
in einen albtraum verwandeln von
monsterwellen auf dem meer bis zu den
größten störungen der erde
ein hurrikan kann bis zu 600 millionen
watt leistung erzeugen wenn seine
monströsen winde auf land treffen
verwandelt sich ein tropisches paradies
in ein katastrophengebiet
september 2014 vor der küste der
mexikanischen halbinsel baja california
braut sich ein gewaltiger hurrikan
zusammen laut ersten vorhersagen soll
der störung raus aufs meer ziehen aber
dann dreht er und hält direkt auf dem
beliebten ferienort cabo san lucas zu
schicken und ihn war sehr mächtig mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von rund 200
kilometern pro stunde
viele touristen reisen ab aber nicht
alle menschen können die stadt verlassen
sie suchen in notunterkünften schutz und
warten nicht zu der sturmjäger george
foreman er fährt im sturm entgegen
ich war dort mit meinem kameramann steve
greifen den satelliten aufnahmen nach
hält der sturm direkt auf unser hotel zu
bringen
wir dachten dann können wir ja auch
hotel warten bis er kommt und dann kam
er
das ganze gebäude biete die leute im
hotel stapelten verzweifelt möbel gegen
den eingang um den wind draußen 2 1
wir haben jetzt kurz nach 10 und so
heftige böen hatten wir den ganzen abend
licht es dröhnt wie ein flugzeug so
klimt nur ein sehr schwerer sturm
das war's mit dem fenster plötzlich
gegen 22 uhr 30 hört es einfach auf wir
sind jetzt im auge von harry kennedy
im zentrum eines hurricanes ist es
gespenstisch windstill
es war eine fast tödliche ruhr richtig
still im auge des hurrikans hat man eine
verschnaufpause aber im moment ist
trügerisch denn der sturm hat schon viel
losgerissen und wenn man das auge
durchquert hat wird alles in die andere
richtung
eine stunde lang herrschte ruhe dann
heult der wind wieder auf mit mehr als
160 kilometer pro stunde wie aus dem
nichts wird der sturm wieder starker
meine kamera sie lag auf der theke davor
ein handtuch plötzlich war es als wäre
eine bombe hochgegangen
die komplette glaswand in der lobby
explodierte einfach
die überwachungskameras fangen den
moment ein
tief zieht sich gerade seine socken an
und dann rum
und jetzt sehen sie was die für ein
profi ist er schnappt sich sofort seine
kamera
ein anderer typ und ich duckten und
schnell hinter der rezeption die theke
war einfach das nächste möbelstück
runter runter
oh
mein gott bleiben sie da unten
unten bleiben
alles sind auch noch
ich bin in gefahr der heftige sturm der
durch die lobby bläst und all das zeugs
es darum lassen und puls so etwas kann
einem den kopf abreißen ich dachte
wirklich okay das gerät außer kontrolle
irgendwann habe ich an mir runter
geschaut und gemerkt dass mein bein
blutete einschnitt am knie habe ich gar
nicht gespürt es war klar wir können
dort nicht bleiben es ist ein rennen
sicher
wir haben einfach in diesem raum aus und
hoffen dass die fenster halten wenn
nicht haben wir den hurrikan hier drin
es gab keine schweren möbel zum drunter
hat wir saßen wie ratten in der fall
mein kameramann steve saß in der lobby
fest und ließ die kamera einfach laufen
die unglaublichen aufnahmen zeigen wie
der sturm die lobby zerstört
als die decke und er kam wurden die
stromkabel rausgerissen die komplette
elektrik lag frei
spürst du wie sich die band bewegt das
gebäude während wann war klar hier
können wir nicht bleiben wenn die
fenster nachgeben sind wir tot okay lass
uns einfach rennen
unser ziel war das treppenhaus ein guter
ort um einen sturm auszusetzen denn es
liegt im innern des gebäudes und ist
solide gebaut
okay wir werden es versuchen
als wir die lobby durchquerten merkte
ich steve ist weg
ich muss ihn finden ich hoffe er ist
okay
also bin ich wieder runter in die lobby
dort hörte ich wie jemand nach mary es
war steve er war in die toilettenräume
geflüchtet
ich dachte nur gott sei dank
es ist jetzt kurz vor zwei das
schlimmste ist überstanden aber jetzt
sieht man was der hurrikan in der lobby
angerichtet hat
komplett verwüstet nur vom wind von der
sturmflut waren wir verschont geblieben
eine sturmflut gehört zu den größten
gefahren während eines hurrikans der
wirbelsturm drückt riesige wassermassen
an land dieses hotel lag zum glück
oberhalb der wasserkante aber in der
umgebung verursacht odile sturm und
wasserschäden von mehr als einer
milliarde dollar elf menschen kommen ums
leben
die list der stärkste hurrikan der die
halbinsel baja california bisher
getroffen hat
die hurrikansaison in mexiko dauert nur
ein paar monate aber gewitter können
jederzeit zuschlagen dieses paar macht
bei seinem schnorchel ausflug in der
nähe von cancún eine wahrhaft
elektrisierende erfahren sie denken dass
sind wir schon bleiben wir doch draußen
und genießen die natur aber
vorher noch 111 ii
das ist der eigentliche blitz man sieht
die nur für den bruchteil einer sekunde
sie rennen einfach zurück zu ihrer hütte
ich würde vermutlich heulen oder
ausflippen
es ist sommer und bei einem gewitter
oder starkregen ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit doch sehr hoch dass
es auch mal blitzt ich glaube sie haben
das gewitter unterschätzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die mündung des rio katongo in venezuela
hier gibt es pro jahr rund 1,2 millionen
blitzeinschläge manchmal bis zu
3.600 pro stunde dieses spektakel
verschaffte der region sogar einen
eintrag ins guinness buch der rekorde
märz 2010 das kreuzfahrtschiff louis
majesty ist mit knapp 2000 menschen an
bord auf dem mittelmeer unterwegs der
himmel ist klar aber es ist stürmisch
die bühne erreichen fast 100 kilometer
pro stunde
wenn man auf seiner kreuzfahrt ist denkt
man das ist so ein riesenschiff da
passiert schon nichts
plötzlich trifft eine gewaltige welle
das schiff
[Musik]
alle wollen zum fenster und rausschauen
drei riesenwellen jede mehr als zehn
meter hoch krachen auf das schiff
fenster gehen zu bruch glassplitter
fliegen umher
das ist brutal völlig ohne vorwarnung
es ist eine monsterwelle die sieht man
nicht kommen
monsterwellen treten spontan auf es gibt
keine einzelne ursache dafür es muss
nicht mal stürmisch sein sie entstehen
wenn verschiedene faktoren
zusammenkommen
der wind muss stimmen ebenso die
strömung und beides muss ich treffen
manchmal vereinen sich auch zwei oder
drei wellen zu einer größeren die folgen
sind verheerend
durch die monsterwelle sterben zwei
passagiere 14 weitere werden verletzt
[Musik]
wasser hat so viel kraft wie heftig wind
sein kann wissen die meisten menschen
aber wasser ist viel dichter als luft
und hat viel mehr wird
wenn also so eine riesenwelle gegen ein
schiff schlägt oder gegen einen menschen
ist das einfach zu viel
[Musik]
über monsterwellen weiß man erst seit
kurzem bescheid viele jahrhunderte lang
hielt man die plötzlich auftretenden
wasserwände für seemannsgarn erst 1995
registrierte ein digitales gerät wie
eine 25 meter hohe welle eine bohrinsel
in der nordsee traf
wie brachial solche wellen auch kamenz
männer genannt sein können muss die
grand voyager im februar 2005 erfahren
nach dem zusammenprall mit einer
monsterwelle sind die maschinen
ausgefallen
jetzt hat das kreuzfahrtschiff
manövrierunfähig in einem gewittersturm
der das mittelmeer zwischen italien und
spanien auf peitscht mit
maschinenkraft kann man so etwas
durchstehen soll wenn die motoren
ausfallen ist man ja sie ausgeliefert
wie eine plastikente in der badewanne
über 700 menschen sind an bord
die wellen jeden das ganze schiff hoch
man kann den kiel deutlich sehen da kann
man sich vorstellen welche kräfte bei
diesem sturm im spiel sind das schiff
kommt aber nicht ganz aus dem
gleichgewicht es kennt hat nicht und
schaffte sich wieder aufzurichten
nach buchstäblich aufwühlenden stunden
gelingt es der crew schließlich eine der
maschinen zu starten mit der hilfe von
schleppern schafft es die grand voyager
an die küste mehrere menschen sind
verletzt das schlimmste sind aber zum
glück nur knochenbrüche
monsterwellen sind nicht die einzige
bedrohung für kreuzfahrturlauber vor der
küste von grönland filmen diese
passagiere einen gewaltigen gletscher
sie genießen den spektakulären anblick
als plötzlich knackende geräusche aus
dem eis ertönen
diese gletscher sind wie lebewesen man
hört sie knappen und knarzen weil sich
ihr eis bewegt da herrschen enorme kraft
während es im wasser schwimmt man hört
viele urus und aß und dann ganz
plötzlich
schauen sie mal wie die ganze seite des
gletschers nachgibt
wenn hunderte tonnen eis ins wasser
stürzen wird eine enorme menge wasser
verdrängt mit enormer kraft
[Musik]
eine riesenwelle rollt direkt auf sie zu
die passagiere sind fassungslos
aber der skipper handelt
geistesgegenwärtig und steuert das boot
aus der gefahrenzone
die flutwelle app erst kurz vor ihnen ab
sie sind völlig durchnässt aber in
sicherheit
bist du okay
bin ich habe mich dem tod noch nie so
nah gefühlt
deshalb hatten die ausflugsboote immer
respektvollen abstand zu den gletschern
während sie näher dran gewesen hätte das
boot leicht kentern und sinken können
und dann wäre es wirklich brenzlig
geworden
was wissen sie über gletscher
[Musik]
75 prozent des süßwassers auf der erde
sind in gletschern und polareis gebunden
würde all dieses eis schlagartig
schmelzen stiege der meeresspiegel
weltweit um 70 meter an die meisten
küstenstädte auch metropolen wie los
angeles oder shanghai lägen unter wasser
oder wenn jack 160 stundenkilometer in
wyoming hat es ein paar skifahrer
eiskalt erwischt wegen des tores das der
seilbahn betrieb eingestellt war es der
wetterbericht hatte sturm gemeldet aber
die bühnen sind viel heftiger als
erwartet
das schneetreiben ist so stark dass die
liftbetreiber kaum etwas sehen können
sie können die gondeln erst einholen
wenn der wind nachlässt
sie hängen in einem 45 grad winkel wenn
sie den lift bewegen könnte der sturm
die gondeln abreißen oder gegen einen
pfeiler schleudern man kann die armen
leute kaum sehen sie schaukeln hilflos
hin und her für einen moment lässt der
wind lange genug nach um die skifahrer
sicher unterzubringen
[Musik]
aber plötzlich trifft eine besonders
starke böe die seilbahn zwei lift
mitarbeiter sind noch an bord
sind sie nur wie das wackelt die leute
da oben sind extremen wind kräften
ausgesetzt
man kann sich nur festklammern und
hoffen dass man es zurück auf die erde
schafft solche stürme sind in diesen
höhenlagen nicht ungewöhnlich aber wenn
man in einem skilift festsitzt wird es
richtig gefährlich
banges warten endlich lässt der wind
nach und alle schaffen es sicher zurück
im benachbarten colorado wird die winter
wunderwelt für einen schneemobil fahrer
zur eishalle
man sieht dass der schnee ganz locker
ist und man sieht auch wie er mit seinem
schneemobil dadurch pflügte dient
plötzlich eine lawine
[Musik]
wow wenn ich als schneemobil fahrer da
reingeraten will ich in riesen
schwierigkeiten
das muss sich anfühlen als würde man von
einer tonne ziegelsteine getroffen
er hat eine schneebrettlawine ausgelöst
das passiert wenn sich eine
schneeschicht durch gewicht oder
schwingungen in bewegung setzt wie eine
glasplatte die zersplittert und an den
berg hinab rollt
[Musik]
das war eine lawine
der schneemobil fahrer überlebt
ordentlich durchgeschüttelt aber
unverletzt der schnee war leicht und
locker genug er wurde nicht komplett
verschüttet er schafft es sich selbst
und sein fahrzeug aus dem schnee zu
befreien
wenn man von einer lawine verschüttet
wird ist es als wäre man unter beton
begraben
man kann sich nicht bewegen er hat
extrem viel glück gehabt
zeit für ein kurzes lawinen quiz
[Musik]
90 prozent aller lawinen bei denen
menschen zu schaden kommen werden durch
sie auch ausgelöst oft von
leichtsinnigen skifahrern mehr als die
hälfte von wanderern
2400 meter hoch in den französischen
alpen bereitet sich dieser
extremsportler auf einen
lebensgefährlichen stand vor er will auf
skiern eine fast senkrechte bergwand
runterfahren seine helmkamera läuft
schon
das ist ziemlich steil ungefähr so
da fährt er runter da der schnee bewegt
sich für einen moment schneller als er
der skifahrer löst eine lawine aus sie
ist nur wenige sekunden hinter ihm er
rast so schnell er kann
da möchte man jetzt nicht hinfallen denn
sonst überrollt sich die lawine
blitzschnell
oh mein gott sehen sie sich das an
gefährlicher und extremer geht es gar
nicht
und dann löst er den fallschirm aus und
es wird klar er weiß genau was er da tut
fantastisch da dreht sich einem der
magen um wie auf der achterbahn und wenn
man nach hinten schaut sieht man wieder
schnee den hangeln abstürzt
ein zweiter skifahrer hängt an einem
fallschirm weiter oben und filmt den
atemberaubenden stunt
sehen sie mal wie die lawine darunter
kommt
wenn die ihn eingeholt hätte wäre er
unter tonnen von schnee begraben worden
[Musik]
diese adrenalinjunkies schaffen sogar
noch eine punktlandung auf den füßen mit
ihren skiern und fallschirmen
eine spitzenleistung und perfekt
durchdacht ich ziehe meinen hut vor
diesen jungs
andere brenzlige situationen lassen sich
nicht so gut planen stellen sie sich vor
ein golfball trifft sie mit 50 sachen so
fühlen sich diese hagelkörner an
und manche erfordern höchste
konzentration
in myrtle beach south carolina suchen
strandbesucher panisch schutz vor einem
gewitter
[Musik]
aus den dunklen wolken bildet sich ein
wirbel eine wasserhose sie ist
gefährlich nah an der küste
es sieht zunächst aus wie eine harmlose
wasserhose die normalerweise nicht viel
schaden anrichtet
meistens bleiben diese wirbel über
wasser und wirken dann wie ein normaler
schauer aber wenn eine wasserhose genug
kraft aus einem gewitter zieht und auf
land trifft kann der tornado gewaltig
werden genau das passiert hier
er hat ganz schön in sich
diese atemberaubenden aufnahmen haben
touristen von ihrem hotel ausgemacht
die leute die das filmen sind in großer
gefahr ein tornado kann einen spielend
leicht umwerfen oder über die
balkonbrüstung werfen man sollte weg vom
fenster nach innen in einen flur oder so
etwas glas bricht zuerst auch wenn die
wende noch stehen
der schwarze trichter der sich da bildet
sieht aus wie aus dem film der zauberer
von oz es ist ein ausgewachsener tornado
wie man ihn sonst in den great plains
sieht
wenn man den wirbel in bodennähe
betrachtet sieht man eine riesige
trümmerwolke da wird klar dass das nicht
harmlos ist
gebäude werden verwüstet menschen rennen
um ihr leben es ist wahnsinn ein tornado
der kategorie f2 der richtig schaden
anrichtet
pass auf mein gott er ist im wasser oh
mein gott
der gefährliche tornado steuert auf eine
touristengruppe zu die das monster aus
einem anderen blickwinkel filmt
während sich der wirbel über das meer
bewegt kann man sehen wie das wasser
hoch gesaugt wird und in den wirbel
fließt man bekommt eine gute vorstellung
davon wie luft um den tornado herum
zirkuliert
seht euch das an habt ihr gesehen wie
nah das war
die wasserhose pflügt über drei
kilometer den strand entlang
die wirbelstürme verursachen
millionenschäden und verletzten mehr als
35 menschen
immer auf den neuesten wetterbericht
hören nicht einfach an den strand fahren
und sagen ach wenn es regnet gehen wir
halt rein denn hier gab es nicht nur
regen sondern einen tornado
[Musik]
wo kann man am ehesten eine wasserhose
sehen
florida ist die weiße rosen hochburg der
usa fast 500 dieser wirbelstürme werden
im sunshine state jedes jahr registriert
das warme wasser und die feucht heiße
luft die aufsteigt bieten perfekte
bedingungen für tornados
[Musik]
von florida nach russland in sibirien
findet ein schöner sommertag am strand
ein jähes ende
[Musik]
wenn ein sturm aufzieht kann es schnell
dramatisch werden
plötzlich ist er da und entlädt sich
ziemlich direkt über den leuten den
badegästen feld sprichwörtlich der
himmel auf den kopf in form von
hagelkörnern
erst nachtmann und denkt sich was ist
das denn aber dann wird's ernst
[Musik]
sie suchen schutz und rennen um ihr
leben
das tut fürchterlich weh
stellen sie sich vor ein golfball trifft
sie mit 50 sachen so fühlen sich diese
hagel kanal man sich ja was es bei den
autos anrichtet riesige beulen kaputte
scheiben stellen sie sich mal vor so ein
ding trifft sie am kopf
[Musik]
für solchen hagel braucht man schon ein
sehr heftiges gewitter kommt mit
aufwenden die die hagelkörner nach oben
tragen und in der atmosphäre halten
der hagel wird immer größer bis die
oberen luftschichten die eiskörner nicht
mehr halten können sie schießen die
pistolenkugeln richtung boden bei so
einem sturm ist offenes gelände im
freien der letzte ort an dem man sein
möchte
so heftig der hagelsturm auch tobt
ernsthaft verletzt wird an diesem strand
niemand aber in einem wohnviertel nicht
weit entfernt schlägt der sturm
ebenfalls zu
[Musik]
hier wird es extrem gefährlich und zwar
rasend schnell
eine heftige sturmböe ist das komplette
dach von diesem haus
und der wind wird immer stärker die
situation läuft völlig aus dem ruder
der sturm tötet zwei menschen als ein
baum auf ihr zelt stürzt in dem sie
schutz gesucht haben
wie groß können hagelkörner werden
das hier gilt als das größte h gekommen
das je in den usa gemessen wurde es hat
einen durchmesser von 20 zentimetern und
wiegt fast ein kilogramm
120 zentimeter hagelkorn das vom himmel
fällt allein die kraft die benötigt wird
um es lange genug in der wolke zu halten
bis das super kalte wasser auf diesem
hagelkorn kondensiert unglaublich der
eisbrocken fiel während eines sturms
2010 in south dakota vom himmel es gab
erhebliche schäden an autos und gebäuden
an
diesem strand in spanien droht gefahr
nicht durch eis sondern durch wasser
nach einem heftigen sturm rollen starke
brecher an die küste
vielleicht wäre es schlauer sich auf
etwas höheres terrasse bewegung warum
glaubt sie stärker als das meer zu sein
mutter natur so du willst mir wohl auf
der nase rumtanzen pass lieber auf jetzt
rennst du auf den letzten drücker war es
nur ab
ich frage mich wie es sich anfühlt am
kai entlang geschleift zu werden erst in
der nächsten übung konnte sie da wieder
raus
das nennt man einen kühlungseffekt die
wände sind gebogen also wird die ganze
energie auf den punkt konzentriert wo
diese frau steht sie verliert den halt
und jetzt strömt das wasser mit aller
kraft zurück und sie wird mitgerissen
zum glück ist hier nichts passiert aber
sie hätte auch gegen die felsen
geschleudert werden können gegen das
meer sind wir machtlos es ist einfach so
unglaublich stark
übrigens wenn sie das nächste mal von
der südsee träumen bedenken sie bitte
folgendes
ein großer teil von hawaiis stränden
besteht aus papageien fischkot
[Musik]
papageienfische benutzen ihr schnabel
artiges gebiss um algen von korallen zu
knabbern beim abtauen des riffs nehmen
die papageienfische kalziumkarbonat auf
das am anderen ende natürlich wieder
herauskommt als sand ein hawaiianischer
papageienfische kann bis zu 360 kilo pro
jahr ausscheiden
sand spielt auch beim nächsten problem
eine rolle sobald sie da rein fahren
wird es stockfinster
im taiwanesischen tilgungen fährt ein
auto an einem berghang vorbei es regnet
und die des cam am armaturenbrett läuft
da oben sieht man den wasserfall es hat
zuvor also offenbar heftig geregnet
in asien vor allem in china und
südostasien gibt es häufig starke regen
stürme und dann passiert
was passiert als nächstes
kennen sie die antwort
plötzlich fällt ihm diese haus große
brocken vor die nase der muss mindestens
fünf oder sechs tonnen wiegen
die bedingungen für einen felssturz sind
perfekt ein sehr steiler hang und viel
regen
wenn es richtig schüttet war ich der
boden auf einem berg kann die erde
dadurch ins rutschen geraten die masse
wird immer schneller und man kann sie
nicht mehr aufhalten der brocken hat so
viel wucht dass er die kleineren felsen
einfach zur seite drängt
hier kommt eine menge erdmasse den hang
runter der felsbrocken steht auf der
kippe mit nur ein bisschen mehr schwung
hätte er sich noch mal überschlagen und
das auto wäre platt wie ein pfannkuchen
platt ist das auto nicht aber stark
beschädigt
die insassen kommen zum glück mit
leichten verletzungen davon
wo fand der größte erdrutsch der welt
statt
der größte erdrutsch der je
aufgezeichnet wurde ereignete sich am
vulkan mount saint helens im us
bundesstaat washington
1980 lösen sich nach einem erdbeben rund
60 quadratkilometer berg an der
gewaltige erdrutsche reißt den unter
druck stehenden vulkan auf wie eine
sektflasche die eruption ist verheerend
die aschesäule recht 25 kilometer in den
himmel der wind treibt die wolke weiter
teile des bundesstaates versinken in
dunkelheit
von der us westküste nach broken hill
australien ein gewittersturm hat eine
wand aus staub und sand aufgewirbelt die
riesige wolke rollt über den highway und
versperrt autofahrern den weg es ist
gigantisch wie viel staub so ein sturm
auf wirbeln kann das gewitter selbst ist
kilometerweit weg man merkt nicht mal
das gerade 1 tobt aber diese staubwolke
rollt direkt auf einen zu
ein pärchen möchte seine familie über
weihnachten besuchen und fährt weiter
sobald sie da rein fahren würde
stockfinster
es ist so viel staub in der luft und
jedes dieser kleinen staubteilchen
blockiert das licht ein bisschen
rechnet man das auf milliarden partikel
hoch kommt kein licht mehr durch
um das auto herum wird es tiefste nacht
hast du das fernlicht an das macht es
nur schlimmer
man kommt leicht von der straße ab weil
man nicht sieht wo sie anfängt und
aufhört und mit dem fernlicht blendet
man sich in dem staub nur selbst wir
fahren gerade durch diesen staubsturm
aber es ist nicht nur die sicht auch das
auto muss eine menge aushalten wenn bei
diesem staub der motor laufen soll das
ist schlecht für die gesundheit und das
auto man muss an fahren anhalten und
warten bis es vorbei ist
aber bitte keine vollbremsung das könnte
zu einer massenkarambolage führen
sicherheitsexperten empfehlen bei so
einer staubwolke rechts ranzufahren das
licht auszuschalten und abzuwarten
nichts davon macht dieses pärchen
trotzdem haben die beiden glück und
schaffen es durch den sturm wo gibt es
die stärksten sandstürme der welt
starke winde aus der sahara blasen jedes
jahr rund 28 millionen tonnen sand über
den atlantik bis in den amazonas
regenwald den pflanzen dort liefert der
sand wichtige nährstoffe
[Musik]
die gleichen winde die den sand rund um
den globus wen können im luftverkehr
chaos anrichten starke seitenwinde
zwingen diese kleinen flugzeuge im
britischen birmingham zu nerven
aufreibenden landungen
turbulenzen sind eine sache aber diese
scheer winde dicht über dem boden sind
etwas ganz anderes
dieser pilot fliegt seitlich an wie
geplant
dieses manöver lernen piloten für
anflüge bei seitenwind die nase des
flugzeugs muss gegen den wind gerichtet
sein sie können nicht mit beiden
fahrkarten gleichzeitig aufsetzen
ein förder bis zum wind gerichtet damit
dieser sie während der landung nach
unten drückt
dann erst setzt das zweite verkauf
für erfahrene piloten mag das zum alltag
gehören aber die passagiere dürften nach
so einem ritt noch ein bisschen urlaubs
reifer sein
der insel flughafen von madeira ist für
seine türkischen winde bekannt die große
boeing tanzt in der luft wie ein
papierflieger
nach so einer landung klatschen alle
alles ist gut gegangen respekt vor
diesen piloten und dem flugzeug
ingenieuren die maschinen sind so
konstruiert dass sie das aushalten
in der blackrock das hat in nevada
versammeln sich jedes jahr zehntausende
menschen zum berühmten burning man
festival
hier werden die kunst liebe und
gemeinschaft gefeiert aber diesmal wird
die party buchstäblich gestürmt von
einem gewaltigen staub teufel
in der wüste hat man kaum vergleichs
punkte aber bei diesen staub teufel
sieht man gleich dass er riesig ist
mehrere stockwerke hoch und erhält
direkt auf die leute zu der hammer ist
die person die das filmt bleibt dann
verstehen
in der wüste herrschen perfekte
bedingungen für staub teufel die sonne
brennt vom himmel und der sand leitet
die wärme gut die obere schicht heizt
sich auf
die heiße luft steigt nach oben und die
kühlere umgebungsluft wird in diese
strömung gezogen
daraus entsteht im prinzip ein kleiner
wirbel usw sich trägt beginnt er zu
wandern
normale leute würden vor einem staub
teufel einfach weglaufen ausgenommen
sturmjäger oder natürlich die besucher
des burning man festival
die sind ja auch solche abenteurer
ich glaube die haben sogar spaß schauen
sie mal da waren leute mit dem fahrrad
in diesem staub teufel herum verrückt
[Applaus]
die leute beim burning man sind etwas
exzentrisch für sie ist das praktisch
ein sahnehäubchen
viele staub teufel sind harmlos andere
können windgeschwindigkeiten von fast
100 kilometer pro stunde erreichen da
hilft nur abstand halten
diese staub teufel tobt auf dem mars der
außerirdische wirbelsturm ist 34 meter
im durchmesser und bewegt sich mit fünf
meter pro sekunde
vom weltraum zum grand canyon
hallo mädels
ein paar freunde genießen ihre
wandertour plötzlich hören sie so etwas
wie wasser rauschen in der ferne ein
paar kilometer entfernt hat es
vermutlich geregnet bei ihnen tröpfelt
es nicht mal hast du es mag ja ich werde
das filmen man kann das wasser kommen
hören
wenn man wasser so tosen hört weiß man
dass es ganz nahe sein muss und
wahrscheinlich ist es so schlimm wie es
sich anhört
hier kommt es ziemlich wild wow das
kommt ganz schön schnell und dann ist da
plötzlich ein fluss wie aus dem nichts
wahnsinn vielleicht sollten wir lieber
hier weg
man muss irgendwie nach oben das ist
eine sturzflut in den usa kommen
jährlich mehr als 100 menschen in diesen
reißenden wassermassen ums leben
die hier fließt wirklich schnell sie
reist sie war felsbrocken mit sich und
sie höre definitiv auch menschen fort
spülen wenn sie der mittenrein gerieten
und sie wird immer schneller
sturzfluten treten in sehr trockenen
gegenden oder halbwüsten auf
wenn es sehr heftig regnet und es dort
keine vegetation gibt um den regen
aufzusaugen fließt ihr sehr schnell über
die oberfläche im prinzip ist es als
würde man was auf eine platte kippen von
ds direkt runter läuft
die wanderer hier können sich auf höher
gelegenes terrain retten das ist immer
regel nummer eins erst nach vier stunden
lässt die flut nach wie gestrandete
gruppe wartet geduldig bis sie ihren
canyon track fortsetzen kann
es schiebt sich vorwärts das ist
verrückt
das nächste wetterphänomen wirkt wie aus
einem science-fiction-film aber es ist
real riesige eismenge überfallen eine
feriensiedlung an einem see in minnesota
es gibt immer weiter und weiter all das
eis das immer weiter auf einen zug
kriecht da denkt man ich werde verrückt
guck dir das an
es wirkt fast wie ein lebewesen wie es
sich darüber land schiebt
da müssen schon sehr spezielle
bedingungen zusammenkommen
erstmal muss die eisdecke auf dem wasser
aufbrechen
dann braucht man anhaltenden wind der
über den seeweg und das ganze eis an
land schiebt
es fliegt über den busch
das eis hat tonnen kräfte es kann eine
veranda einfach aufbrechen es kommt
durchs fenster und kann ein ganzes haus
aus dem fundament schieben ja es drückt
dagegen
man kann es nicht stoppen die kräfte
sind zu gewaltig
mein gott hörst du das das ist die
reibung wenn das eis über dem boden
kriecht es rumpelt fast für ein güterzug
die auf einen zukommt
es hat die häuser erreicht es kriegt die
hauswände hinauf wenn es sich nicht
unten durch schieben kann kriegt es nach
oben sieht das an es geht direkt durch
ihr verdammtes haus da hilft weder ein
schneepflug noch eine schaufel man kann
mutter natur nicht aufhalten das alles
richtet in der siedlung nur wenig
schaden an aber weiter unten am see
werden zwei bootshäuser durch das
gewicht des eises zerquetscht die masse
hat sich bis auf eine höhe von 9 meter
aufgetürmt
ich stehe direkt darunter so hoch ist
ich glaube in jedem steckt ein kleiner
wettern
selbst wenn man angst hat muss man doch
hinschauen man guckt zu und denkt nur